so maybe
it's useful to talk about a few
contrasting thinkers in there so
one is uh leo tolstoy oh yeah
who um i think not many people know
is uh an anarchist yes uh a christian
and a christian anarchist yeah so he uh
came to despise government for his
deceit and his violence
but to him the the christian principles
of non-violence i think
are important oh yeah and this kind of
pacifist kind of mindset
of uh you know it's better to someone to
punch you than to punch them back
so he's in that way at least i've read
he influenced mlk and gandhi
what do you think about this flavor
color
of the anarchist flag of non-violence ah
non-violent opposition
i i i will put the caveat that
it bothers me when people bring up mlk
because he's become so corporate
yeah and everyone just brings him up
without knowing about him one of the
things that martin luther king
did so very well was that he forced
people to face the consequences of what
they were putting forward
you want to be racist you want to be for
jim crow you wanted for segregation
okay it's easy for you to do that from
your living room now turn on your news
and you see men and women in suits being
attacked by
dogs being attacked by fire hoses and
beaten by cops
just so they could sit on the front of
the bus and now for a lot of people
who were still racist who were still had
animus toward black people are watching
this
and it's gonna be a lot harder to be
like
i'm okay with this i'm okay with human
beings even ones i regard as somehow bad
or inferior
to be beaten and attacked by uh trained
dogs
and they're not doing anything in
response that strikes to i think a very
basic nature of especially american like
okay
whatever you're for i'm not for people
getting beaten and attacked
when they're not really doing anything
so i think uh
pacifism is something that's very easy
to make fun of
but people don't uh underestimate how
powerful it is
for someone to say you can do what you
want to me
i'm not gonna fight you back i just want
to live peacefully and have the same
rights as you
and to say screw you you should get
beaten
that's a hard pill for a lot of people
to swallow so i think he was
really and gandhi of course as well were
excellent in that regard there's a
little bit of machiavellianism to it you
know they've both been beatified
regardless saints
but their strategy worked very very well
for their purposes so i think uh
just all of us when you see someone you
know in this kind of christian you know
i know iran obviously it's nothing very
highly christianity
but if he's someone who's willing to
you know take a punch and just say you
could do whatever you want to me
i'm not going to hurt somebody else
instinctively
and maybe this is kind of a hack most
people want to side with that guy
step in between and be like oh okay
let's take a step back because whatever
led to this is not tenable we need to go
back to the drawing board if the
consequence
is people are having uh these as a
result of my decisions and actions so
i think that aspect of anarchism uh
is very very in certain context healthy
and much smarter and more sophisticated
than people give it credit for and let's
also point out
that tolstoy wrote warned peace and he
wrote anna karenina
so this was not some naive or innocent
whatever word you want to use
he knew the nature of evil he knew how
bad things get
so he wasn't saying at all that human
beings are inherently nice and kind
he was saying it's much more effective
to not fight back and to force them to
face that
i i i'll give you another example i was
talking to i was on the show
trigonometry
and i was talking to the hosts and one
of them talked about how someone he knew
had been uh in the gulag or his mom was
born the gulag grandma
and after stalin died and the soviet
union liberalized and lots of the people
in the gulags were freed by khrushchev
and and so on and so forth
he i didn't know this many of the or
some let's say some
of the guards of the gulags killed
themselves because they had genuinely
believed
that everyone in these camps was there
for a reason and when they
found out that these people were
completely innocent didn't even have
trials
and that they were the ones forced them
to work themselves death and starve
they couldn't deal with that guilt so
when you are
a pacifist or non-uh non-retaliatory
and you're forcing someone who's using
force like look what you're doing
look what you've become for some people
some people don't care
you know like the guy in scare tactics
like i mentioned earlier where for a lot
of others
they're gonna be like okay is this who i
wanted to grow up to be they will have
that little flame of conscience that you
and i talked about earlier there will be
like
how did i get to the point where there's
this lady
who wants to ride the bus and she's you
know lovely dressed
put together and i have a sending a dog
on her
what kind of person am i for some of
those people
they're gonna be like okay i can't be a
part of this i don't even understand the
politics
i still am racist but i'm not going to
take part
in this atrocity well that was uh for
him
from the individual perspective perhaps
he
he calls that christian but listening to
that voice of conscience
like whatever that is in you
so for tolstoy it seems like
anarchism from the individual
perspective
is uh silencing the rest of the world
and listening to the
the for him probably god-given voice of
conscience yes
and so that that's what it means to live
embody anarchism and to body
christianity i would think he would say
but he would see those as basically
that's correct uh
yeah so in terms of forms of government
the christian government is one that's
no government
yeah correct
you